it is great to be joined today by dr.
Mick who is an associate licensed couple
and Family Therapist with a PhD in human
development he hosts a nightly twitch
stream called game sessions with a
therapist
dr. McGregor 8 to have you here I'm
looking forward to our conversation
great to be here I'm looking forward to
it as well so we've talked quite a bit
about the relationship between the
content of video games and movies and if
and how that translates into people's
real-world actions we've talked about
technology addiction we've talked about
anxiety and a video game addiction all
of these sort of issues but I'm
interested in sort of first hearing from
you top-level I mean how do you think
that the prevalence of anxiety and
depression that we are seeing today and
the way technology has developed
interact like do you have some kind of a
general thesis about how that is all
working sort of like for Western humans
right now yeah so I mean one of the
things that I think we see a lot in
terms of anxiety and with technology and
we see this especially in teenagers but
I think we see it pretty much anybody
that has a presence on social media it's
one of the things you see a lot is what
we call dissonance between what a like a
person's real self and their what we
call their digital persona which is
essentially where what people put out on
the internet or out just kind of in
social media yeah it's not all it's
consistent with how they are in real
life and so sometimes there's a degree
of anxiety that people experience of not
being able to live up to what they put
out digitally and if you are in a
digital space more often than you are in
you know traditional social spaces that
can cause a significant amount of like
social anxiety or just general anxiety
when you're out in the real world trying
to interact with people because people
are so used to being behind a screen
when they do it yeah this is also I
would argue acutely destructive when it
comes to like the world I operate in
which is political discussion where if
the political discussions that are
happening on Twitter were forced to take
place in real life you would see I would
estimate only like two to four percent
of the aggressiveness trolling and sort
of
ideas of violence that you see presented
online because in in the real world most
people don't actually act that way and
there is a very destructive nature to
the effect it has on the narratives I
think of course well the thing is in
real life if a person sitting there in
person it's a lot easier to hold them
accountable I mean when you're in an
online space and you're behind a
username and you have anonymity and then
all of a sudden you know a person could
just delete their account or could just
turn off their computer then there's not
really a way to hold people accountable
to the things that they're saying so you
control you can you can say nasty things
to people you can put some kind of crazy
opinion out there that isn't founded in
anything and there's no there's no
accountability to it like there would be
in real life so before we move on to
sort of some bigger picture issues about
mental health and and we could talk
about some real-world violence and some
other issues there on the one hand we
have a pretty good sense about the ways
in which too much technology use in
social media and and other types of
technology can cause anxiety and
depression at the same time there there
is the idea that gaming for some people
can create a sort of flow or zen-like
state that can reduce anxiety so how do
we kind of square that the same activity
can be both positive and negative which
is not new I mean that exists in a lot a
lot of areas of life but how can we
create more of a sort of objective
perspective about video gaming and
social media use when it seems to cause
both a and the opposite of a I love this
question a lot and this is one of the
spaces that as a therapist they try to
operate within is that yeah video gaming
can be a source of it can be a real
resource for people who are having a
hard time with anxiety and can really be
a space to have an outlet or to be able
to manage anxiety and yes it can cause
anxiety as well I think the thing is one
of the most important things that we can
do one is have more dynamic
representation of gaming in the media
right now you you only ever hear about
video gaming when there's like a mass
shooting or something like that and the
shooter happened to play video games
although that is changing a little bit
we're starting to see with like eSports
being on the rise or you know somebody
like ninja being on The Ellen DeGeneres
Show like we're seeing more dynamic
representation of gaming but I think
that's a really important part is to be
able to have that and I think that you
know people can learn a huge amount of
skills when playing video games such as
like leadership and problem-solving and
they can build their distress tolerance
which is a big thing with anxiety in
video games and I think if you have a
bridge of somebody who can connect
what's happening in the digital sphere
with what's happening in real life and
somebody who really knows how to
navigate both spaces there's a lot of
things that people can learn in games
that can translate into real life and at
the same token if it's causing anxiety
for somebody having people that having a
better idea of how technology works
makes it so that people can enter that
space maybe help a person through that
and mitigate that a bit in real life so
I that to me is a real important thing
is to be able to have more awareness of
what the digital space is actually like
particularly with video games so when we
hear after a particular mass shooting
for example that we need to look at
mental health ok what exactly could that
even possibly mean like because when we
identify that someone who goes out and
commits some horrible crime had a mental
health issue okay that's a fair sort of
like first step that's perfectly
reasonable but then the question is well
exactly what is it that you're looking
to do and I'm talking about only people
operating in good faith there are people
operating in bad faith who just say that
in order not to not talk about guns I'm
not talking about that with you right
now and in good faith what is it exactly
that are sort of options that are on the
table when we talk about addressing
mental health issues when we want to try
to address the real world violence
that's taking place well I think the
primary issue right now is access to
assistance with mental health I mean one
of the things that's so terrible I in my
opinion in America right now is that
there's just not a lot of access to
mental health and that people's access
is really dictated by insurance and so
what we're talking about is you know if
a person's struggling like say a person
is thinking about wanting to commit one
of these heinous acts and maybe doesn't
even have an access to talk to somebody
about that then they're probably more
likely to act on it so I think access is
a huge one and then you know making
thoughts like this maybe less taboo so
that a person could sit in a therapy
office and talk about it and share it
and then we can actually gameplan and
help a person through it instead of just
further isolating a person so that's
what I really think we're talking about
here is just access you know whether
it's at the level of a school whether
it's at the level of community insurance
being more willing to reimburse for it
and allowing mental health to be part of
what they're covering instead of just
physical health like that's what we're
talking about I think in the United
States do you think that mental health
professionals right now have enough
clout when it comes to signalling that
someone does present a risk to others
potentially and and do you think that
mental health professionals are
empowered to the degree that they should
be to actually be able to take action
that would have an impact when they
identify such individuals I would say
yes I mean we have protocols that we
felt like as a therapist I have
assessments that I might do of to
determine whether a person's going to be
of harm to themselves or to somebody
else and there I mean it varies by state
whether you have duty to warn laws but
you know there's also the morality of
that if do you need to warn if
somebody's going to be a danger to
themselves or others but I do think that
therapists do have the ability to do
that and to be able to assess for that
kind of thing and then you know I think
to have to be able to coordinate with
say like a police department in a given
area that maybe has training and also
how to handle something like that so
that there's a bit more of a
coordination there I think that's
important but I do think that if it's in
a space where as soon as somebody
mentions that they're having thoughts
like that a person freaks out and
immediately goes off running and telling
people that doesn't necessarily create a
space for a person to be able to talk
about it either but I do believe that
mental health practitioners do have the
ability to do that
of assessment and to coordinate with the
people that they need to coordinate with
for sure how would you assess the stigma
associated with going to a therapist and
getting help I mean so as one example to
kind of contextualize this we know that
in the military there is significant
hesitation to actually go and seek
mental health treatment not necessarily
because of the stigma of actually going
and doing it but because there is
significant risk if you are labeled as
someone who is having certain types of
challenges you risk being being sent
home so to speak or losing the position
that you have so it's like that very
specific risk aside from those
particulars depending on the jobs that
you're in it societally has the stigma
around mental health treatment decreased
or do you still see this as a big
problem um it's a two-part answer one I
still see it as a big problem and it's
my mo it's actually why I do my stream
is to try and D stigmatize therapy but
you see in certain pockets of the
country where it's okay to be a
therapist like if you go out on the west
coast like everybody has a therapist and
everybody talks about it and but if you
get into like areas like the Midwest and
suchlike people are a lot more close to
the chest in terms of whether they're
seeing a therapist or not and I think
like yeah the stigma is still there I
mean I would say for a majority of even
clients that I work with and colleagues
work with one of the first barriers to
people even coming to see me is this
stigma they're worried about what people
are gonna think hell they're even
worried about what I'm gonna think is
the therapist um about them being there
which and so I'm you know that's a
barrier that's kind of constantly having
to be broken down like one of the first
things I'll say to people is this is an
immense sign of strength that you're
here it's an immense sign of
self-awareness like this says nothing
about like you being weak it says that
you're able to identify that you need
assistance from an outsider and there's
certainly nothing wrong with that and so
I think yeah I mean when you have people
that are still making fun of people for
going to treat mental health or see
mental health is this separate thing
from physical health like it does
perpetuate some degree of stigma for
people seeking it out honestly I would
just say this because I'm a therapist I
believe everybody could use a therapist
you don't have to be in dire straits to
have a therapist
it really is a sign of strength and it's
cool to be vulnerable and go talk to a
therapist and I will ride that till the
day I die one of the areas of huge
progress that I've seen in this space is
the development of what's called primary
care integration which is related to so
many of the symptoms that cause people
to just go and see their regular doctor
never ultimately have a physiological
cause attributed to them and we know
that at least some fraction of them are
sort of physical manifestations of
emotional circumstances that people have
do you see the possibility of having
more primary care doctors equipped to
say hey you know what I work with
someone who actually is very
knowledgeable about exactly what you're
experiencing would you be interested in
talking to them and smoothing that
transition into obtaining some of these
therapy services that seems like it has
huge potential to me oh my yeah I would
love that
that would be wonderful I think I think
most therapists would like that I mean a
person's first point of contact in terms
of taking care of their health is
generally their primary care physician
so yeah absolutely like if there was a
network there where primary care
physicians knew of the therapists in
their area and there was a level of
coordination with that and in integrated
care there I think that's I think that's
wonderful and then that falls back to
access again like it's gonna be hard for
a primary care physician to refer to a
therapist when the person's insurance
might allow them to see the primary care
physician but not say like me a couple
and Family Therapist so I think there
needs to be some level of coordination
with insurance around that - and a push
from primary care physicians would be
wonderful for that we've been speaking
with dr. Mick who's an associate
licensed couple and family therapist PhD
in human development his nightly twitch
stream is titled game sessions with a
therapist dr. Mick really appreciate you
talking to me today I appreciate you
having me on David it was a pleasure